[Music]
today we're going to talk about a rather
serious topic
the future
hello this is hof the hoff hoffman here
with our auto pro pad g2 turbo
today we're working on a 2018 chevy
silverado we're gonna be adding a new
key to it
as you can see theflight is on this key
is not programmed
we do have one existing key however in
this case we're going to clear all keys
in order to just have these two
programmed
to start we need to read the pin code go
to mobilization
gm usa
read security code bcm read pin code
yes we do want to read the pin must be
connected to the network which i am
this will pop up once more to read the
pin code in a second
read pin code
2049 is our pin
now back out of here
immobilizer by vehicle chevrolet
usa silverado
2017 plus program keys without smart
all keys lost i'm going to turn this off
and on again
another pin two zero four
nine
password is two zero four nine
and we'll be back in about ten minutes
and we're back here about nine and a
half minutes down a few more seconds
left
the fight's still on
all right so it has been 10 minutes the
flight is out
insert the key you wish to program from
the ignition on position then press ok
yes we do want to program another key
because this is a two key system
yes commission off
press okay next key to be programmed
off remove key press okay
you do not want to program another key
ignition off
remove key
now sometimes when doing this the theft
light will stay on even if the keys are
programmed
quick workaround on that is to go back
and pull the pin code again
in doing so that will clear the fault
codes but we'll see if that happens on
this one
[Music]
out new key is in
truck starts with the first key
[Music]
start to the second seat second key
theft light goes out
program complete 2018 chevy silverado
auto pro pad g2 turbo thanks for
[Music]
watching